[Music]
M mother
Roan I have heard your call and wanted
to say upon your water since I was 3T
tall you've seen it
all you've seen it
all I watch the man who rolled
you switch from sails to steam and in
your belly you hold a treasure few have
ever seen but most of them
Dream Most told
[Music]
dream yes I am a
Pirate 200 years too late the Cannons
don't Thunder the nothing a plunder I'm
an overfed victim of Fate arriving too
late arriving too
late done my S of
smuggling run my share of grass so I
made enough money to buy myami but I
piss it away so fast it's never meant to
last never meant to
[Music]
last well I've been drunking now for
over 2 weeks I pass out and i r and i
sprung a few leagues so but I got to
stop wishing I got to go fishing I'm
down at Rocko bottom again it's just a
few
friends just a few
friends I go for a younger women
live with several little while no I ran
I'm away come back someday and still
could manage to smile just takes a
while it just takes a
while mother mother oan after all these
years I found my
occupational hazard being my occupations
just not around I feel like I've
drown I feel like I'm
drown going to head up
down